and less than two months the iPhone 15
Pro Max will finally be in our hands as
well as the gaping thirteen hundred
dollar hole in our wallets yes I say
1300 which sounds insane but we just got
a report from Barclays that the new
flagship iPhone could easily cost
between 1200 to 1300 now I couldn't
believe it at first but after some
research I found 10 reasons why apple is
going to be raising the price so let's
jump right into reason number one which
is a big upgrade to storage we recently
got some reports that apple is finally
going to be upgrading the Pro Models on
the 15 lineup to 256 gigs of Base
storage now right now both the pros and
the regular models come with a 128 and
upgrading to 256 by itself costs 100 so
it would make sense for that price
increase if apple is truly giving us 256
on the 15 Pro now why would Apple do
this well first of all right now you
have an equal level of storage on the
regular and Pro Models 128 so it's a
little bit weird because previously the
regular models were at 64 gigs so there
was some sort of incentive to jump up to
the Pro Models because you got double
the storage for the extra price so it
was another thing that kind of
incentivized their Pro Models and we all
know Apple wants you to buy the pros and
now getting into reason number two we
finally have another new finish on the
Pro Models which the last time that
happened was with the iPhone 10 when
Apple introduced stainless steel well
now on the 15 pro and pro Max apple is
finally giving us titanium yes titanium
which is going to be just like the Apple
watch Ultra and honestly I love the
titanium finish because it is just so
strong and actually lighter than
stainless steel as well now unknowns 21
who was the guy the leaker who leaked
and confirmed that titanium is coming he
also gave us the exact titanium metal
that apple is going to be using it's
grade 5 titanium which is apparently
ti-6ai V4 I have no idea what that means
but that's cool he has the actual
material so I'm excited for that because
it's gonna kind of change the feel and
it's probably no longer going to be as
much of a fingerprint magnet and now for
reason number three we're going to be
getting a brand new action button
exclusive to the Pro Models now you've
probably heard about these leaks before
well basically there's going to be a new
button just like your kind of volume
buttons right here it's going to be
replacing the mute switch apparently
there's supposed to be pressure
sensitivity customizable functions and
everything else but before I explain the
new leak that just came within an iOS 17
beta version leaking the actual features
of the action button I've got to give a
shout out to our partner case Q for
their magic stand case which is the best
value case you can get since it's very
rugged high quality and stylish while
also featuring magnets for all of your
macsafe accessories but making it even
better the max if ring is actually on a
hinge that works as a finger grip and a
stand at a variety of different angles
for things like watching videos or even
taking photos so go ahead and check out
the discount info and links down in the
description below now getting back to
the action button and the new features
that were discovered within iOS 17 beta
4. here is what you're going to be able
to customize and do with that action
button you're going to be able to do
accessibility features just with the
push of the action button you're going
to be able to use your different
shortcuts that you can customize to
basically to anything you want you're
gonna of course be able to turn on
silent mode you're going to be able to
open up your camera and even take videos
or photos with a simple press of that
button you can turn on the flashlight
which is much easier than having to kind
of go through the lock screen and turn
it on you're going to be able to switch
through Focus modes turn on the
magnifier feature turn on translate and
start translating conversations
instantly and even turn on voice memos
and record just with the push of a
button without having to open it at all
that is already so exciting so it makes
sense why adding this functionality
might raise the price now getting into
reason number four apple is planning to
give the iPhone 15 Pro Models the
thinnest bezels on any smartphone ever
yes breaking records with 1.55
millimeter bezels now that is not going
to be an easy feat because apple is
known for not having the thinnest bezel
so apple right now we just got a report
that they're struggling with the brand
new manufacturing process because those
thinner bezels are going to be harder to
produce and manufacture at scale and of
course those issues are going to cost
Apple money and just a new process
itself is going to be more expensive and
part of that could actually be the new
2.5 D glass process where they're going
to be shaving the glass down towards the
edges of the screen in order to create a
perfect smooth transition between the
new redesigned rounded Edge design and
the glass which is similar to what Apple
has been doing on the Apple watch design
not the ultra because it's flat but the
other Apple watches with that seamless
transition for reason number five for
why it's going to be more expensive we
have of course the new Periscope camera
which is going to be exclusive to the 15
Pro Max now this has a brand new
foldable lens Periscope design which is
much more complicated than a regular
lens but on top of that it's also going
to have a variable Zoom like what Sony
did for the Xperia 1 mark IV not only is
it a static Periscope telephoto lens
with like a 5x camera that comes on the
pixel 7 Pro but the one that's going to
come into the 15 Pro Max is going to be
able to optically zoom from around 3x to
6X within the lens itself with the
actual physical lenses moving around and
zooming now this is going to be the Best
of Both Worlds giving you perfect
Optical quality right at the 3x Zoom
range and also perfect quality up to the
maximum around 6X without having to crop
digitally which ruins the quality and on
top of that Apple also has deep Fusion
which basically Stacks pixels together
to make the quality even sharper it's
likely going to be the best telephoto
lens out there and that's another reason
why it's going to be thirteen hundred
dollars moving on to reason number six
we have the new a17 bionic chip which is
going to be exclusive to the Pro Models
and it's going to be expensive because
it's going to be the first three
nanometer chip ever and also from tsmc
which is going to be very expensive
because right now A tsmc is going to be
charging 20 000 for each three nanometer
and three wafer compared to 16k for the
five nanometer Wafers that's a 25
price boost so it makes sense why apple
is gonna be increasing the cost on the
15 Pro Models on top of that we were
also supposed to get a fully redesigned
brand new GPU for the a16 chip that we
already have but that ended up getting
delayed so the a17 should include this
new GPU on top of all of the EXP
offensive three nanometer advancements
so it kind of makes sense now on to
reason number seven this is a pretty
simple one but it is important because
the iPhone 15 Pro Models are going to be
upgraded to eight gigs of RAM finally
because right now both the regular
models and the pros have six gigs but
we're gonna go up to eight which is
gonna help with opening up all your apps
keeping everything Snappy multitasking
that is going to be nice and it also
does factor into the price even though
it doesn't actually cost Apple that much
in terms of the actual material prices
but Apple does factor in the nice
feature and convenience of having eight
gigs for number eight of course we have
the switch from lightning to USBC now
that might actually not cost Apple that
much money like in terms of materials
but they might actually be planning on
increasing the price of the iPhone just
to account for the loss on mfi made for
apple lightning royalty Revenue that
they are going to be now losing out of
now that they're getting rid of
lightning so maybe that's another reason
why they're increasing the prices and
then also to add to that there's also a
chance that Apple could be giving the 15
Pro Models Thunderbolt ports instead of
regular USBC which is going to be insane
because it's so much faster up to 40
gigabits per second transfer speeds
absolutely insane compared to the 480
megabits on these lightning phones and
then that would actually increase the
cost more because of the extra Tech they
have to pack in and now moving on to
number nine Apple does have to pay for a
newer wireless tech like the Snapdragon
x70 5G modem which is going to be a lot
faster and more efficient than the
current x65 since it's built on a
smaller node process so I'm sure that's
also going to add to the cost and then
that's another reason why apple is
working on their own modem so they no
longer have to pay another company for
it which of course includes profit
margins added on top for that company on
top of the actual cost and apple wants
to build it themselves so that they keep
those profit margins within apple and
then finally for reason number 10 for
why the price is going up the iPhone 15
Pro after many years is finally going to
get an improved lidar scanner now that
hasn't changed since the original one
came out I think it was the iPhone 12
Pro that got lighter yes it is going to
be upgraded so it's going to work a lot
better and of course that's extra things
to add to the price so honestly with all
of the new features that are coming I'm
not surprised that apple is raising the
price especially with the main reason
which is the bump up to 256 gigs of Base
storage that is very exciting so if
you're worried about the price maybe
that will help you feel a little bit
better hopefully you enjoyed this video
and if you did let me know down in the
comment section below and click that
Circle above to subscribe for more
videos like this one and check out one
of those two right over there thanks for
watching and we'll see you in the next
video
[Music]
foreign